[Music]
are you denying clap if you laugh you
loose
do not laugh during this video cuz then
you will loose and if you're loose then
you like and if you like you lose and
let me know in the end of the video if
you laughter if you lose good now let's
go
this time we're not gonna react to any
dank memes cuz YouTube just seemed to be
striking down extra hard lately that the
yellow the yellow sign is everywhere and
I'm getting a little fed up so we're
gonna keep it nice and family-friendly
please so I thought we're gonna do the
25 most viewed twitch IRL videos that I
will be a good time let's go everybody
[Music]
give them a hand job and I just barely
touched his penis and he just like all
over my stomach okay you just say my
name there Leah just not try and hide it
there it makes it work okay good nice
family friendly thank you good one
I just once had a guy touch my belly he
just all up
why is she talk like that i won
relatable though relatable story it
always makes for a good laugh when you
can be like that never happened to me
those bottlee and she's a marks you were
to play then we could go into the same
lean together it would be really cute
and then I like I don't know if I would
I mean it'd be cool but I think cuz
there is a champion that I dunno and he
kind of looks quiet think I'd be a
Malphite player cuz he's pretty like
he's edgy and such you know no cuz you
can be the bottom and I'll be on top but
yet so
are you kidding me right now did he just
say you can go bottom and I go top in a
MOBA that joke has never ever been said
before and I can't believe how awkward
he just became that is just crazy oh my
god sometimes social interactions they
just go like wow what happened here
besides video games there are some of
your hobbies that you have you try and
change subject right away it's not that
easy even try to help you what do you
mean it's not that awkward I'm super
awkward and I didn't even find that
awkward just joke about it and move on
god dammit teenagers teenage love am i
right
you go by and I coat up oh there's a
little kiddo running at me hi what is it
a clown a clown
I'll go check it out if the police
officer livestreaming out what the hell
this is that seems kind of like a bad
idea did he did he film shooting the
clown or why I need to know oh [ __ ] yeah
damn I mean I was bound to happen sooner
or later right
did he does he continue does he get his
subs as well like does he if someone
steals my computer clearly they get my
channel as well it comes with it
it's a package they want you to ask the
ladies behind you you can either I
didn't know wait don't
they seem like they're up for it
so painful come on
that we're totally up for it I'm glad
the girl left they they could have a
good time with those old ladies there's
got to be a game where like you
everyone's slowly loosens the cap a
little cork here and then puts it o it
up to there I know you know it's like
Russian Roulette Oh what do you think
was gonna happen
thank God he wore glasses Jesus Christ
dude
to twitch and we're gonna we're gonna
watch right now thank God man damn that
couldn't that kind of really they just
have a laugh about it they might be
terrified yeah throw me in a basement
okay shut the lights off and play
Nickelback non-stop for hours on end
I will want to die and I guarantee you
Jesus Christ stop hating on Nickelback
foreskin Tim donated $10 you said like
you Tim we appreciate that
I'll read that I better dude I thought
he's like doing it for fish yeah that
makes sense actually enforces
Oh admit defeat did you all go
he broke he typed the letter yeah
where's your heart he typed the letter
he wrote the letter for instead of come
on Zack I'm sorry the one dollar
donation from Jenna - oh he was so salty
just stop just admit defeat
he broke he typed the letter yeah
where's your heart he typed the letter
he wrote the letter for instead of jet
it's cool
you found for the oldest trick in the
book
shout-out to genitals
my workouts can't tell me to go away
[Music]
you know
I mean she was really fit so I I do
understand what she was saying
are they Korean Japanese
[Music]
why did it take him so long to react
he's like what he's through [ __ ]
understand what they just happened he's
like do I pretend that that's my friend
or not
it seems so different when you get money
on the street rather than people paying
you online it does seem like your actual
picker